alles brennt komplett zerstört die karte
[Gelächter]
wieder wird nicht
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
der app zusammen mit gome hd der steht
gerade stehen wir drinnen man könnte
meinen ich heiße kamera den ich hasse
kopf datei ich heiße goma hatte hallo wo
nicht einmal und hier ist echt bei
vielen unternehmen ist das jetzt einfach
mal schaffen hier fertig den knopf
dauerhaft da kannst nur da mal rüber
laufen natürlich oft genug auch sehr
nett von dir ja damit du wir mal coins
einsammeln kann es wie viel hast du noch
mal ich habe eine menge ich habe meine
kommentar ich hatte gar nichts und
deswegen weil das alles so komisch und
ich frag mich schon erwarten not ja ist
ja so alles besser ausgeschöpft sein
kommt nein
doch der palette von beiden du hast mir
ja auch damals noch einen screenshot
geschickt alter wie solche das noch
aufholen das geht gar nicht mehr ich
hoffe ihr habt geht hier noch ein gebiet
1000 folgen damit ich jedoch aufholen
kann nicht meine hallo ich hoffe aus
dann kann ich meine führung noch weiter
ausbauen
ich habe euch in den kommentaren gelesen
ja kann man hat die punkte völlig
unverdient der alte sagt er ist auch
völlig er ist immer weiter voran
gelaufen um was es geht hoch gegangen 18
ich habe da so ein schalter gedrückt ja
habe ich gemerkt wir sollen wieder so
ein schiff nämlich wetter gekommen nicht
einfach wieder raus aber ich hoffe nicht
damit haben wir erfahrung so also ich
habe wegen eines kaputten herds auch
kaputt geht
ich hoffe nicht weg weg weg
also ich habe 14 teams wir hatten der
letzten das model emma und die ultra
wasser blog below haben wir noch in etwa
ich weiß nicht ich kann manchmal bei mir
in kontakt
erstmal will ich mir ein paar bot hier
ich hatte auch noch einzelne menschen so
ich möchte mich das ganze jahr machen
wie es ja auch steht mehr aufgestellt
die mit dem boot warten wir noch eine
kiste
ich will den bürgern zu dir beruhigt das
macht spaß
[Musik]
oder will komme habe ich ihn lieber nein
habe ich nicht sein stadtrat kasan
springen wahrscheinlich müssen wir nach
oben und finden dort schalter ich hab
ich mir so logisch erschließen weiß habe
ich gelernt mich echte klasse ich bin da
ganz starker ich bitte da oben es schon
sein wenn ein guter springer und ich hab
ich nicht geortet
natürlich bin jetzt auch hier oben aber
westermann oder war so ich bin auf hier
bei dir bewusst auf die decke aufpassen
gleichkommen würde decken sprüngen ich
bin jetzt hier ja genau der der danach
den schafft dann schafft man genau aber
jetzt wie ich hoffe einfach dass ich
hatte einfach alles was wo man sich
halten muss und dann muss man denken
umgeschaltet muss ja hallo gestellt die
kiste in schalter in kuchen und betten
plus ultra baath-partei hier oben ist
den schalter wo du brennst gezwungen den
schaltern und ich habe ja ich wollte
dieser stadt höchsten verlassen hier
diesen ländern werde möchte ich gerne
sieht man es mal wieder
ok
nicht so worauf denn hier auf dann
hierüber aber ich bin richtig drehen
wenn er richtig drin im springen
ich habe ja angelaufen ist hat genau
darüber bisher ich diese hinkomme du ich
bin richtig dreckig wenn wir am anfang
ja manchmal schon wieder runter gefallen
ich bin fertig ja das hättest du mir
nicht sagen müssen
es ist natürlich einfach nicht
selbstverständlich ich könnte mal eben
einen big mac mit mac os x hemberger du
hier so ein kleiner warst du
wahrscheinlich schon drin ja bestimmt
mit mit den betten
ja genau und der mit den blöcken so mit
blöcken blöcke die jahr kollege
jetzt hat mich komplett runter geschubst
nur da geehrt wieder zu dir wenn du mich
der hochschule ich wage hat kurz oben
ja aber du warst du etwas voreilig
die wurde brown verfolgt mich okay
geschafft und versteht one out of
resources so hier ist eins von vier
[Musik]
wochen rund englisch dass eine röhre von
haben wir hier gründer ich frag mich nur
haben wir gerade ein viertel der kater
es geschafft ich habe keinen plan
ich schaue mal nämlich weg zur world
tour
nein nein nein ich bin ich ein halbes
jahr oft rot neustadt teleportieren
hatte mal tp bin attasch der welt gerade
schon server restart passt ja ich bin
wieder ganz am anfang habe ich hier zu
den worten ja und hier nicht immer
überall und ich hatte ständig hier bin
ich auch aber die habe ich jetzt mal
schon genommen
ja du hast damals wirklich alle kisten
gewechselt war und im stand gerade in
fünf minuten irgendwie wieder hoch kommt
ja ja irgendwie schon
ich bin froh am arsch der welt
positionieren dann fliegt man dann halt
ich's kämpfen ist noch fraglich
hochgeflogen ich habe karten weg
gefunden
huhu hier lang bot sich am besten komme
ich war doch schon mal hier
wo waren wir noch nicht hier waren wir
noch nicht glaube ich nicht erkannt
worden flogen fliegen los stell dich ja
ich warte hier
wir wollen aber nicht daheim ist youtube
zu so sarkasmus
wir haben jede menge reihe noch mehr
oliver kahn ja ja ja genug
nein hab ich ausgenommen so hier steht
darauf ja ich komme ich auf alles kaputt
gekriegt zwischen wird durch nein ich
habe keinen plan steht kross kate major
das ist nicht okay okay wir brauchen
einen plan ich weiß nicht genau wo wir
gerade sind wir sind ja hatte ich weiß
media.com tourist ist verschuldet als
die argumente ok ich folge dir das kennt
man ja auch schon von der alten teilen
mal solche schöne ausflüge über die
karte hier kennt den weg zurück auf den
schalter drauf von denen lieber nicht ja
deswegen bin ich gestorben
eigentlich schade buchen
das war nicht so toll ist noch ein game
dann will ich nicht ich weiß nicht warum
ich hier fliegen kann
ich bin nicht im game mode ich habe
vorher noch ein game dann so richtig
ausgenutzt schon alle jobs gerade
doch mal richtig ins gericht wenn du
fällst alter was soll das noch so wie du
bist schon wieder los
ja weil du mich getötet hat ich habe
keinen brustpanzer weil ich hab nur
schuhe
mein freund ja ich habe angst weil du
auch am 100 300 aber ich dachte du
schlägst mich leider waren drei hühnern
drauf deswegen die habe ich darunter
gefasst auf es gefährlich hier jetzt
wird ach naja einen tod muss noch
recherchiert werden so finde ich nein
runtergefallen selber ja ok verdammt
schnell weiterkommen nur importen und
dann beschleunigt so viele punkte hat am
porten gegen schwer hat den ersten teil
der karte hierdurch porten geschafft
gerade eben von einer vorher steht auch
die hand gegeben wieso kann ich da nicht
gut springen also ich kann das auf jeden
fall ja ich jetzt auch wohin es mich
sehr wohl
[Musik]
ich drücke mal wieder hier für dich ein
mensch bin ich dann heißt das wir ja der
komme ganz normal was im moment ist
immer noch was im angebot
schlag mich dass er uns ja und jetzt du
nicht mal
ich helfe dir helfen du hast noch eine
minute sagt dass server und studiere ich
geschafft kommt gibt der besten tarife
und nicht schon wieder so ein monster
level wo alles voll mit monstern ist ein
check von einander neuer wird auch mal
hier den checkpoint jetzt haben wir zwei
denn hier bitte
so kommt und ihr könnt hier rauf rauf
rauf da rauf rauf rauf auf worauf es
schafft es und er hat es geschafft alter
lassen kraft wie das kleine ich würde
sagen ich mal ganz in weiß dass er noch
hier schaffen ist doch so ein penner der
eiskalt den schalter wäre ich fast tot
ich platt oder gefallen ja was muss man
einfach nur noch auf dieser platte
darauf ehrlich ja keiner muss sich ja
nicht gut und schnell
ok so freunde wir sind wieder live
aufwand live für euch hier mit dabei
hdh egal ob man drückt den knopf merkt
ja endlich war ich habe kein brustpanzer
ich halte das nicht mehr aus und ich
helfe dir ja auch noch vielleicht tot
jetzt hat er halt mal ganz bestimmt du
bist doch so fern halt da lässt es geht
wieder los
hab ich dich wenn du hier grad meine
finger sehen konnte wie den durchblick
ist
ich möchte nichts läuft eigentlich auch
bei dieser aufnahme ist klicken werden
eine dann einfach so vieles samstag kann
man nicht rein
und doch noch doch doch ich hab ich
hab's ich hab's sind willkommen da
kannst du probieren als noch nicht
abgeschafft da gab es auch das ging
richtig einfach ja komm trink dich jetzt
kommt auch noch die kontrolle hätten
warum wolltest du dich denn jetzt man
warum denn nicht
du bist doch einfach nur gerecht
das war einfach nur gerecht ist oder wo
bin ich hier bin auch hier bei dir
angenehm mein name ist möchte ich lebe
doch nicht mehr lang
[Musik]
nein wir wollen wir das denn geschafft
da wieder hochzukommen ich könnte ja
krieg und leid ich kann das auch ich
kann auch tricksen
ich habe auch getrickst so aber man hier
bin ich mich einmal port weil du mich
getötet hat dann meckert warum ich fühle
mich verletzt
ich weiß nicht ob wir richtig sind hier
aber anscheinend doch hier über das
grüne rüber was haben wir hier haben wir
ein checkpoint das heißt hier der
richtige weg oder wenn ich jetzt eine
falsche richtung laufe recht so aber ich
höre auch so groß ist sie auf uns
schießen beziehungsweise place teile
finden woanders lang gelaufen
wahrscheinlich laufe ich gerade wie ein
anfang
[Musik]
oder nur schauen wir wo sind dass hier
wo geht das hier hin
ich glaube hier war mir noch nicht jetzt
eine kiste die haben nicht geöffnet
haben 21 drin daheim
das ist nicht euer ernst doch da hatten
wir den komme der wünsche abgeschossen
das läuft im moment unternehmen momentan
ist er hier durch meine geschichte von
crafter der ich helfe ihm ein leben lang
ich trug immer den schalter war nicht
nur konnte jetzt eine kiste und schon
also dann klaute mehr vor der nase die
points weg von lässt mich im stich
was du mir geholfen mich ja eben gerade
hier beim knopf drücken wenn überhaupt
richtig ja du bist hier hand gelaufen
ich bin auch ausgesprochen
[Musik]
bei mario barth what happens
da ist keine true love you 40
introductions und how to fix
hier will die kaktus boden rissen die
boden ich habe kaktus bohlen gesagt wenn
du richtest du hast wohl actus schreiben
die kommentare kaktus oder parkt kaktus
den gotthard war gut fast so weit wie
ich schon nicht mehr weiter ich war
weiterhin kilo schwere auf die schon
dein youtube juan nein ich war darauf
aber nun springt nur an
nein wir machen das so stellt sich drauf
ich schlag ich darüber okay geben steige
ich mal dahin wird dann tot dann
dastehen wenn man genau da wo ihm
bleiben nicht reicht sagen 21 ich möchte
leben oder 3 2 1 1 über wow das auch
außerhalb verbogen und eine junge passt
mal auf miedl ja du weißt wieder hase ja
ihr habt eine schule freunde einer
erhält was machen sich unter schmeiße
ich bin gerade am ende
so ein richtiger treckerfahrer der ein
jammer
da sind wir mal wieder auf dem gleichen
stand hier ich habe eine schule vor
einer richtiger treckerfahrer ihr genau
gar nicht alles sagen und er dauernd so
gerne ich weiß wieder trecker fährt
alter dann komme ich immer so ich weiß
wie der hase läuft
man hat also mädchen meine ich natürlich
ich bin tot schon wieder fast winkel ich
brauche auch mal wie es im brustbein
tausche points gegen prozess habe ich
eigentlich noch einen hut aufhaben gut
kann ja manchmal die heilung geben was
ich falsch weiß man truck der haltung
ihr was ich habe schon mal verschwendet
das war jetzt der ruf habe ich auch noch
obst das war deiner wohl
es war daher wohl das motto kaputt
gemacht ich hab eine neue hingesetzt
rhythmus noch nicht kenne
egal ich bin ich halt noch die eine hat
ja im inventar vorne halt noch mehr und
du hast da die böden wir alles drin hat
man auch diesen brand komplett zerstört
die karte ja nee du bist david nicht tot
lassen das hast du doch dass mario
texture pack selena oder ja doch habe
ich hier ist die kaktus polen die du da
und allgemein die bohne die ägypter
fordern werden gesetzt dass wie die
aussieht
einfach ein paar weil darauf
konzentrieren den stümpfl da diese
angibt und bis das interne kommen jetzt
schafft das wenig
aber das war das wasser schon wieder wir
sind ja schon wieder ein ende angelangt
die nächste folge mit bei ghom hd seien
dort geht es dann weiter mit den
kompletten facelift in jedem moment
deswegen ihre idee auf das was aber in
der haut rein und schön
und ja wahnsinnig klein ich bin ich so
alt war als ich mit torten
ok ok denen es dann beim nächsten mal